oh
I know the change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
if I learned anything from meeting
princess on a billboard is that
sometimes you just have to take a leap
let's start our new life
[Music]
home you'll see
it's all part of the adventure that's
not an adventure that's a landfill a
land filled with Adventure
Robert congratulations
oh it's what they call a fixer-upper yes
once your peasants have dug out the moat
and added a turret and a balcony from
which you can sing I see it now okay
Melvina Monroe I would have sold you
this house but I deal in slightly more
upscale
in andalasia the hardest part of life is
finding your happily ever after this
world's very different and this world is
not to your liking then you must change
it
[Music]
I wish
Jumping Jelly stick wait how am I
talking I wish
[Music]
I wish for a fairy tale life and it's
all gone terribly wrong or terribly
right
the last stroke of twelve nothing will
be as it was before
Oh
[Music]
Giselle what have you done
thank you
that's a Wiki wicked good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]